sabe aquela sensação de comprar um livro
novo ou ganhar um livro novo
quando você abre e parece que você está
mesmo
uma história completamente desconhecida
pois bem eu não sei se desde sempre ou
desde quando a minha memória alcança eu
sou apaixonada por livros
eu lembro de ter a coleção do monteiro
lobato e organizar cada letrinha para
montar o nome dele e depois eu lembro de
ter pegado pela primeira vez a minha
coleção da assinatura da turma da mônica
ter ficado emocionada disse me de ver o
meu nome lá também lembro de ler
escondido os livros na 5ª série que não
foram os professores passaram e fica
extasiada com literatura um desejo que
mais marcou foi a versão juvenil de
serrano de berrar e aí eu fui crescendo
e os livros de ficção deram espaço para
os livros de não ficção até que quando
eu entrei na faculdade de economia
os livros técnicos me pegaram de jeito
eu sou apaixonada por economia ou seja
cafona mas eu costumo dizer que a
economia é uma espécie de lente que você
coloca e começa a ver o mundo através
daquela lente e com a economia e você
você acaba direcionando essa sala é a
lente para o que mais se sensibiliza
economia fala da ciência é a ciência da
escassez é muito normal que a gente
estude assuntos como a pobreza a
desigualdade ea partir daí vêm aqueles
questionamentos meio que naturais
será que as desigualdades e qual o
tamanho da pobreza será que a
desigualdade aquela desigualdade
desejável é aquela desigualdade que faz
que a gente é com que a gente escolher
entre ser médico engenheiro advogado
ou será que a desigualdade aquela
desigualdade que enterra o elevador da
mobilidade social que faz com que muitas
pessoas sequer possam escolher entre ser
médicos advogados engenheiros e nessa
literatura nesse avanço nessa nesse
mergulho por essa análise sobre pobreza
e desigualdade parecia que em todos eles
tinham espécie de fórmula mágica
era mais ou menos assim você entende o
tamanho da pobreza entende que essa
desigualdade é aquela desejável a
estrutural se ela foi desejava a gente
não faz muita coesão ou se ela foi
estrutural a gente precisa de uma
fórmula mágica para conseguir superar ea
fórmula mágica era investir em capital
humano funciona mais ou menos assim você
oferece educação de qualidade para todo
mundo e essa educação faz com
os indivíduos consigam ser mais
produtivos ter salários cada vez mais
altos e pronto
consegui atravessar conseguiu
desenterrar o elevador na mobilidade
social
agora a sociedade é com vocês e as lhe
terá a literatura ea nasa em
profundidade ea cada vez livres mais
complexos fórmulas mais complexos
modelos mais sofisticados e à medida que
eu ia avançando nessa literatura
começaram a surgir dentro de mim um
paradoxo na verdade começava a surgir
dentro de mim um sentimento que muitos
de vocês devem ter
sabe aquele sentimento de não vai dar
tempo
eu não vou conseguir tem muito trabalho
eu estou trabalhando muito muito muito e
eu não to conseguindo tô conseguindo
cuidar dos meus filhos dos meus pais dos
meus amigos da minha família e estou
conseguindo nem cuidar de mim mesma
e aí quando esse teto quebrou abrir um
céu de possibilidades mas é aquele céu
de possibilidades que mudam as suas
perguntas mas muitas perguntas meio
michael sanders são os mesmos problemas
mas vocês colocam diante de respostas e
visões completamente diferentes
então chegou a vez de conhecer o lado
oculto da economia
logo de primeira ele já me colocava uma
questão avassaladora
quem faz o jantar de adams mesmo com
essa é uma questão não é ele mesmo
não é ele mesmo e para entender esse
lado oculto eu vou pedir licença vou
contar uma historinha pra vocês
era uma vez uma das deusas que
resolveram fazer uma corrida
essa corrida não tinha um lugar fixo de
chegada ou nenhum trajeto fixo fixo na
verdade o que elas queriam era saber
qual a sociedade que conseguia avançar
caminhar e levar os seus habitantes para
mais longe
então a sociedade se dividiram a
sociedade a essa sociedade que todo
mundo saiu correndo ao mesmo tempo logo
começaram as pessoas já ficaram pra trás
ficaram para trás as primeiras que
ficaram para trás foram as crianças e os
idosos
mas logo os adultos homens e mulheres
também começar a ficar muito cansados e
perceberam que não tinha ninguém para
substituí los e acabaram abandonando a
ainda acabaram deixando a corrida a
sociedade deu uma estratégia diferente
ela fez o seguinte homens e mulheres
dividirão as suas tarefas
os homens corriam ficavam responsáveis
por correr e as mulheres responsáveis
por carregar as crianças e os idosos e
logo começaram os conflitos as mulheres
começaram a perceber ea questionar esse
talvez ela não tivesse a
responsabilidade de segurar crianças e
idosos elas conseguiram correr tão
rápido quanto os homens poder chegar tão
longe quanto eles e que o seu trabalho a
sua responsabilidade era tão importante
quanto a corrida e os conflitos
começaram a ficar tão intensos que
começou a subir garay energia de todos
eles e eles também tiveram que abandonar
a corrida então as deusas se viraram
para a sociedade sim nessa sociedade ser
todo mundo de vídeo de tudo todo mundo
entendia que a competição e os cuidados
tinham a mesma importância
e todo mundo trocava tudo o tempo
inteiro crianças idosos eram cuidados
por homens e mulheres que dividiam essa
tarefa é claro que a sociedade ser foi
mais longe
é claro que foram eles que ganharam a
corrida e essa é uma história muito
bonita
eu achava que dava para viver sem dor e
sem dramas na sociedade a imagina só
nasce em 1984
em 1984 o brasil era muito diferente do
que é hoje em dia a gente estava
passando por um processo de
redemocratização o processo da
hiperinflação
a gente conseguiu superar a gente
conseguiu estabilizar estabilizamos os
preços mas a gente também percebeu que a
estabilização traz outros desafios que
uma economia internacional faz com que
você perceba que as as crises
internacionais afetam a sua economia lo
à sua economia local
a gente foi avançando estabilizando e
também percebemos que mesmo
instabilidade traz outros desafios e as
relações sociais e as relações de
trabalho começarão a serem questionadas
a sociedade das nossas avós mundo das
nossas avós têm se tornado rarefeito as
divisões específicas de gênero já num
em desuso esse mundo na verdade era um
mundo que não é não era só um movimento
do brasil mundo inteiro já falava sobre
isso
amanda já estava estudando os estados
unidos deviam seja tinha lançado pela
carreira solo e o conto da área tinha
quase tanto tempo no mundo quanto eu
existia nele ea gente começou a perceber
que talvez agora as mulheres tivessem é
que a partir de agora a voz das mulheres
se tornando a cada vez mais forte cada
vez mais significativa e daquele mundo
rarefeito das nossas avós
a gente se deparou com o mundo das
nossas mais que colocava para elas uma
dolorosa escolha para conseguir avançar
profissionalmente para chegar no topo da
minha carreira eu tinha que abrir mão da
minha vida familiar
eu consegui ter a minha vida familiar eu
tinha que abrir mão da minha carreira
dá pra entender agora porque menos de
10% das 500 maiores empresas no mundo
são comandadas por mulheres
só que seu nome é linda ela também é
implacável ea gente saiu de uma
conquista inegável uma vitória de poder
participar do mercado de trabalho por
uma necessidade
com os orçamentos familiares cada vez
mais comprimidos com a necessidade de
cada vez mais duas pessoas chefiar
chefiarem as casas e trazerem renda pra
casa a gente se viu diante do desafio de
como conciliar a maternidade com o
mercado de trabalho
na verdade essa era uma escolha para uma
parte das mulheres mas para muitas
outras sequer uma escolha seja porque
são chefias sozinhos usuário seja porque
a gente já está vislumbrando uma crise
muito grande aí eu me colocava daquele
diante daquele desafio e pensava
seguinte como pode
quando eu posso abrir mão como como eu
que fui criada no mundo a primeira
geração exclusivamente para ser uma boa
profissional eu poderia trabalhar
trabalhar estudar estudar e estudar mas
como que para isso e abrir mão da
maternidade
caramba estava pensando em montar um
quarto pesquisando como montar um quarto
montessoriano pra minha filha eu ouvi
que eu confio conversando com ela dentro
da minha barriga gente é criar laços
indigesto destrutíveis que a gente já
tem uma conexão permanente
eu até cogitei pacto naturalizado belo
chute
amo mas assenta passei um pouco longe
então diante de todas aquelas certezas
diante de toda aquela noção de que eu
tinha que escolher mas me todo aquele
conhecimento aquele conhecimento
acumulado aqueles anos de estudos
eles foram virando pó eles foram caindo
caindo até sumirem completamente nos
isolados apartamentos das cidades
grandes mas solitária de licença
maternidade será que a sociedade a não
servia mais será que a sociedade a não
estava atendendo os meus anseios não não
posso permitir isso
já falei vou pesquisar o pesquisador vou
escrever sobre isso
o pai das minhas filhas participa e meu
trabalho demanda muita concentração
muita criatividade eu preciso é pensar
em algum jeito de mudar essa realidade
tem uma professora e uma aluna minha que
estão pesquisando sobre o total do
imposto materno pois materno que isso
preço pela maternidade eu tenho que
pagar pela maternidade mais ou menos não
para aí vamos ver vamos pesquisar vão
tentar entender esse processo por onde o
comércio direitos reprodutivos licença
parental pausa choro que está
acontecendo nada nada continua
trabalhando
choro aumenta a filha mais nova está
quase morrendo corre pro hospital
córregos tal não vai dar tempo não vai
dar tempo fechando a glote chega no
hospital deu tempo
respira você respira não vai dar pra
trabalhar nesse ritmo não faça alergia é
muito séria eu tenho que abrir mão ou eu
vou ter que abrir mão do meu deus o que
eu faço acomoda acomoda acomodou
mas não por muito tempo a filha mais
velha está tudo bem
não tá tudo bem
filtra mim que síndrome nunca nem tinha
ouvido falar sobre isso
claro que vou ficar no hospital que você
só tem três anos de idade
o empregador não mas não vai dar pra me
manter aqui no próximo ano não andou
faltando
não não é possível é a sociedade b é ela
depois de tanta luta depois de tanto
esforço não não eu preciso entender o
que está acontecendo vamos lá tá na
minha família o problema não eu aprendi
a ser mãe delas eu sei cuidar delas na
sociedade também não eu troco com outras
mães
eu sei que o esforço que a gente tem não
é romântico gente não pode romantizar
esse esforço para aí tem pista e
sociedade lembra do imposto materno sabe
que ele diz ele diz o seguinte
depois que a gente tem filho os pais
passam a receber mais com o mercado de
trabalho pra mim há muitas horas eles
acabam ficando muitas horas de trabalho
depois que eles têm pais eles ficam eles
ganham mais mas as mães ganham menos do
que as mães então o abismo entre eles
aumenta significativamente
como é que eu posso mudar essa realidade
como é que eu posso transformar vamos lá
mães do que vocês mais sentem falta
depois se tiver um filho trabalhar
estudar a ficar sozinha paz e vocês
senso de responsabilidade
foi isso que mudou depois da paternidade
o ema não tinha para aí vamos lá vocês
amam seus filhos né claro óbvio vocês
cuidam deles não cuidam claro então o
médico é importante o dever de casa é
importante agenda importante
a festa do amiguinho a febre o grupo do
axa da escola tudo isso é importante não
é então beleza não tinha uma sociedade
que dizia que dava pra gente juntar tudo
que dava pra gente compartilhar tinha a
sociedades e é ela que fazia com que a
gente conseguisse juntar tudo então para
ele deixou recomeçar
boa tarde na minha vida eu tenho 34 anos
eu sou economista professora mãe
em mulher eu cresci achando que a margem
de maternidade do século 21
era uma espécie oi era uma espécie de
leite o grupo pequim em que eu pudesse
criar meu blog no it vila de particular
e que todas as minhas escolhas eram
questionários que poderia ser uma boa
profissional poderia trabalhar onde eu
quisesse eu teria a liberdade sexual que
eu poderia ter uma vida social ativa
mesmo depois de ter filhos mas aí eu
cresci na verdade eu entrei na vida real
e eu percebi que para ser uma boa
profissional eu tenho que conciliar que
a sociedade que eu vivo é uma sociedade
que ainda está aprendendo como conciliar
ser uma boa profissional e ser uma mãe
participativa em ser uma mãe que cuida
dos meus filhos eu sou reflexo de uma
geração de muitas mulheres que tiveram
que escolher entre ser uma boa mãe ou
ser uma boa profissional mas que muitas
até que ficaram pelo meio do caminho
porque não aguentar essa pressão porque
não conseguiram sobreviver a ela
eu sou reflexo de uma geração mas eu
quero ser o espelho próxima onde os pais
podem e querem participar da vida de
seus filhos onde os pais podem ficar em
casa se assim desejarem
a minha forma de mudar o mundo é juntar
esses dois mundos é entender que a
sociedade dos cuidados
ela é tão importante quanto a sociedade
produtiva nosso mundo é construído por
uma parcela muito pequena da população
mas o que faz a gente levantar todos os
dias a nossa vida real requer cuidado
com os nossos filhos nossos pais nossos
amigos nossos amores e desamores
precisamos reconstruir o nosso mundo pra
quê caibamos nele
obrigado
[Aplausos]